enquête au delà des frontières
américaines qui se poursuit également en
grande bretagne à londres laurent
boussier hijack 'les lived in britain
certains auteurs des attentats vivait en
grande bretagne ce matin le titre du
daily mail port fait sur la place
publique ce que beaucoup savaient déjà
londres est une base arrière de
l'islamisme il ya deux jours sur demande
du fbi à scotland yard perquisitionné
cet appartement à brixton dans la
banlieue londonienne à la recherche
d'une femme originaire d'afrique du nord
dont le nom et l'adresse figuraient sur
des documents saisis en floride dans une
maison louée par les terroristes
évidemment la locataire avait disparu
cet homme khaled el fahs oil originaire
d'arabie saoudite est actuellement dans
cette prison multipliant les recours
juridiques pour éviter une extradition
vers les états unis considéraient comme
un lieutenant de ben laden
il aurait fait transité par un compte
dans cette agence de la barclays à
notting hill plus de 50 millions de
dollars 350 millions de francs ces
quelques jeunes qui crient et vendredi
dernier leur haine envers l'amérique et
justifiait les attentats de new york et
de washington font honte à l'immense
majorité des 2 millions de musulmans qui
vivent dissipe mais les chefs islamistes
qui comme cheikh omar bakri bénéficie en
angleterre d'un cadre juridique
favorable continue leur prosélytisme en
employant toujours la même technique
démentir leur propre implication dans
les attentats
tout en revendiquant haut et fort
l'obligation de guerre sainte qui a fait
ça je ne fais pas mais je pense que
c'est une conséquence des atrocités des
agressions de la part des gouvernements
occidentaux et du gouvernement américain
contre les musulmans
au début de l'année le royaume uni a
durci sa législation
les islamistes sont donc moins visibles
qu'avant mais il continue à recruter et
à rassembler des fonds alors que
scotland yard poursuit ses
investigations